- We look at every subject
that we want to film
and then we say, "Well,
what is the best way
"to get into their world?"
It's an amazing moment when you realize
that you are actually seeing
some stuff for the first time.
My name's John Downer, and these are my
incredible team of spy creatures.
Well, I suppose it all
started when I started
making wildlife films,
and I wanted to have that
kind of intimate perspective
to get into the animal world
and actually know what
it's like to be an animal.
Over the years, used technology to get
more and more inside the animal world.
As things have progressed we've moved
from just using remote
cameras disguised as rocks
to where we are today, which is having,
you know, these incredible spy creatures,
which are able to do filming,
cameras in their eyes,
but they look like the animals and
the animals will interact with them.
The whole idea of, you know, using
the robots, uh, came about
when we made a film about penguins.
For the first time, we thought:
"Well, what if we made a penguin cam,
"a living, moving, camera
that looked like a penguin,
"that was able to go into the colony
"and start to get these incredible shots?”
You can't explain it because
it's a dream come true.
I think part of the whole technique is
to try and get inside the animals' minds.
Understanding animal behavior
is key to it all really.
We lost one spy pup to a wolf.
A spy tortoise was
squashed by an elephant.
And I think it's something about the fact
that they look living; it makes them think
before they actually do anything,
and if it's not a threat,
then they kind of...
They quite like it.
The challenges are… They’re innumerable,
because everything is a challenge
from the beginning to the
point you get the film.
The animals, once you get there,
and once you're actually with them,
they tend to be the least
of all the problems.
They usually do deliver
because they do amazing things
and if you've got the
technology to be able to film
close to them in their world,
you know you're going to
get something remarkable.